I spoke with Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo earlier today about the peace
agreement and the Afghan president's
refusal to release Taliban prisoners I
started by asking if that happens could
it void the New Deal there's a long
series of discussions have been taking
place over months and months and it
shouldn't surprise anyone that the
habits of old days are hard to break and
this will be a bumpy road going forward
if you look at the agreement as a
provision about the exchange of
prisoners talks about discussions with
all the relevant parties and moving
forward we have a team on the ground
even as we're sitting here now working
working to deliver not only on that
element right that's a important
confidence-building measure but
delivering on the larger task which is
to keep the levels of violence down and
getting the teams built so that the
first time in 20 years something the
previous two administrations couldn't
achieve a commitment to break with
al-qaeda and a commitment to sit down
with the other side has not been done
before work that that's the next step
that's the next goal I'm confident it'll
be challenged but we're determined to
get there this morning the Taliban
through a spokesman said they were
resuming operations against the Afghan
government and its forces not US troops
that's what they said in response to the
president about the Taliban prisoner
issue how is that gonna work I've seen
lots of remarks just watch what really
happens pay less attention to statements
pay less attention to things people say
watch what happens on the ground there
there's been a lot of work done at
detailed levels about how this will
proceed so far so good
or just hours into this I'm sure we'll
have days when we start and say that the
problems big and but we're determined
and presidents made this commitment our
mission set is to protect America from
the threat of terrorism from Afghanistan
to reduce our cost I was a CIA director
I was a soldier I want to see fewer
Americans having to make their third
fourth and fifth trip there and fewer
Americans coming home injured maimed or
worship never having a chance to be with
their loved one against that's the
president's mission that's what this
agreement is aiming to achieve the
president as a candidate was very
critical of President Obama setting a
timeline and talked about it a lot
you're setting a timeline for withdrawal
of US troops it's very different what
we've done is fundamentally different
than what the Obama administration did
indeed we accomplished what they tried
to do but could not they never got the
Taliban to break with al-qaeda and they
never got a commitment that says if you
execute the following conditions based
that is if the violence levels come down
that is if the security posture for the
United States of America is reduced then
and only then will begin to deliver a
commensurate footprint inside of your
country you can see the deal we've made
it all public there's a there's no
secrets ideals members of Congress will
get to see the to classified
implementation military elements of this
but the deal is laid out there for the
world to see I'm confident that over
time we're gonna get to a better place
there's a president Ghani said this
weekend the most important verification
that needs to take place is not just
Taliban cutting ties with al Qaeda but
with all terrorist groups in our
discussion that is going to be one of
the most fundamental issues this
requires verification not verbal
assurances as you know the Taliban has a
long history with al Qaeda it's detailed
in the 9/11 Commission reports this
weekend on Face the Nation on CBS you
said that it was a strict cut and you
said that that the Taliban would now
work against Al Qaeda and they've made a
break
al Qaeda's mentioned twice in the
passages in the report in the language
it says it will not allow any of its
members or other individuals or groups
including al-qaeda to use the soil of
Afghanistan to threaten the security of
the United States and its allies but
that's not really a break that's not a
very announcing or announcing about
absolute when you say you're not gonna
let him operate there you know Brett
they've done it for 20 years they're not
gonna let them operate it any more
that's that as a central provision
that's one that for 20 years I know
ambassador Lee lozad was there trying to
get exactly that language for two
decades we got it
but what's more important than the
language Brett is the execution
President Ghani here's right
verification matters we'll have the
ability to see what they're doing are
they really living up to that commitment
it's our expectation I I met with him
myself when I was in Doha I look them in
the eye
they revalidated that commitment now
they've got executed now we'll be able
to see the world we'll be able to see if
they truly live up to that obligation
it's important because that's the reason
we went there Brett you know that I
still think about 9/11 and you can feel
you can feel the emotion of that day I
know all Americans can we went there to
defeat al-qaeda we have crushed them and
we put real real costs on the Taliban
over the past months it's why they came
to the table it's why we're having these
discussion that's why I am hopeful that
all parties in Afghanistan will take
seriously the commitment to try to reach
the political resolution that is the
only path forward for the Afghans so
what do you say to skeptical America and
who looks at this and ahead of an
election and says that this was about
living up to a election promise and not
really about the specifics in a deal on
the ground yeah well they're wrong but
besides that promises do matter we're
trying to live up to all the commitments
that we make it's a good thing that the
president made this commitment it's a
good thing we're on the path but that's
not why this timing took place it took
us longer than we had wished to reach
this point these were hard-fought
negotiations the Taliban expressed
interest in having these negotiations
when President Trump gave the Department
of Defense the authority to really go
after them in serious ways and it took
us this long we now have a timeline this
timeline extends past the election and
it is conditions-based
we've got to get it right Brett we have
an obligation to get this right for the
American people we've got to keep
America safe from attacks in Afghanistan
we got to get the footprint right so we
have the resources capabilities and
skills to do what President Trump is
committed to we took down al Baghdadi we
took our customer Rin we took down Qasem
Soleimani we took down Hamza bin Laden
the president has a clear record on
keeping America safe when we determined
to continue to do that everywhere
including Afghanistan John Bolton former
national security advisors calls this an
Obama style deal I know you push back on
that earlier he also tweeted out North
Korea true to form resumes ballistic
missile testing yet again violating UN
Security Council resolutions US policy
must finally face the reality that North
Korea will never
voluntarily stop pursuing deliverable
nuclear weapons see right presidents
made a real commitment to try to find
the path for Jeremy Kim now goodness
almost two years ago made a commitment
to denuclearize we're determined to try
and achieve that the path forward for
the North Koreans is very clear we are
hopeful they will choose it and we're
using every diplomatic tool we have in
our tool bag last thing coronavirus are
you considering moving staff anyplace
besides China out of a spreading
coronavirus environment Italy Europe
other places it's a good question bred
look it's the vice-president and
secretaries are running the elements of
this we're working with them to make
sure we get it right we want to keep our
team safe not only our diplomats and all
the people that fall under the State
Department in countries around the world
but we want to make sure we keep our
soldiers sailors airmen Marines safe as
well it's a complicated decision making
process we're constantly evaluating both
the right number of people to have and
where we can have them mr. secretary we
appreciate the time great thank you
Brian